The mean is simply multiplied by 1.5, and that is 7.5.
To see what happens with the standard deviation in the variance,
recall that the standard deviation is defined as the square root of the sum
of the difference between each observation and the mean.
Since each of these are multiplied by 1.5
and it's then squared, that means this term below the square root gets bigger
by 1.5 squared.
But after we take the square root, it only gets bigger by 1.5
since the square root of 1.5 squared is equal to 1.5.
So the standard deviation of the Ys is 6.
Since the variance is the square of the standard deviation, it's 36.
Since Yi is just the individual observation Xi multiplied by 1.5,
it's 1.5 times 9, which is 13.5.
And the z score or standard score remains at 1.
To show ourselves this, let's just redo the calculation.
13.5 is the data point, 7.5 is the mean. Their difference is 6.
The standard deviation is 6. And 6/6 is 1.